في وقت تتجه فيه كل الانظار نحو ساحه
المعركه في غلاف
غزه تدخل جبهه الحدود مع لبنان الى المشهد
التطور الجديد كان باعلان اسرائيل تسللا
مسلحين عبر السياج الامني في القطاع
الغربي من الحدود مع لبنان ووصولهم الى
منطقه بين عرب العرامشه وكيبو ادميت في
الجليل الغربي واشتباك مع جنود اسرائيليين
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه سته من جنوده
في الاشتباك وان اصابه احدهم حرجه لاحقا
اعلنت سرايا القدس الذراع العسكريه لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي مسؤوليتها عن العمليه
وقالت انها ضمن طوفان الاقصى وانها اصابت
سبعه جنود
اسرائيليين بعد ذلك شنت مروحيات اسرائيليه
غارات داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه استهدفت
مواقع قرب بلدات يارين والظهير وعي الشعب
المتاخمه للحدود ويقول الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه قصف نقاطا لحزب الله اللبناني في
المنطقه وقد اعلن حزب الله ان خمسه من
عناصره قتلوا في القصف بالتزامن مع ذلك
اصدرت السلطات الاسرائيليه تعليمات لنحو
25 تجمعا سكانيا قرب الحدود بالبقاء قرب
المناطق المحصنه خلال القصف كما سارع
الجيش بدفع تعزيزات عسكريه كبيره الى
الحدود مع لبنان سيناريو اشتعال الجبهه
الشماليه كان حاضرا منذ الساعات الاولى
لاق عمليه طوفان الاقصى اذ سبق لوزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه ان اعلنت استعدادها
لتنفيذ ما وصفتها بخطه المسافه الامنه
للمستوطنات والبلدات الاسرائيليه في
الشمال واجلاء قاطنيها الحديث هنا في
الغالب سيكون عن المطله كريات شمونه
نهاريا مسغاف عام زرعيت شلومي فضلا عن
كامل المنطقه من سهل الحوله شرقا مرورا
باصبع الجليل الواصل بين جبل الشيخ وهضبه
الجولان المحتله ويقع على تماس مع بلده
شبعا ومزارعها انتهاء براس الناقوره غربا